but we have this story which I think is
absolutely fascinating on point Nancy
mace taunts left-wing activist she
exposed for extremist tweets with
snowflake Emoji oh my oh my
so here's what happens
a bunch of these uh woke leftists fake
like fake news Liars they make the fake
posts all day and night they lie about
everything because they are psychotic
cultists they're evil people
they're being uh they're testifying
before Congress and Nancy mace asks do
you think rhetoric online is bad and
they'll say yes you think it leads to
violence yes then she pulls up this
tweet from Alejandra carabayo who called
for the public accosting of Supreme
Court Justices
she then mentions you know someone went
and tried to kill Brett Kavanaugh and
it's it's an epic roast this person
carbio is like I need to clarify you
that's not actually what I said and
she's like it's right here you said it
and boom made your SmackDown
when these people come out and they get
angry at Elon and they're like I thought
you were going to protect free speech
and eon's like dude don't share the
location of my jet these are people who
are trying to use our good faith against
us that we would believe in free speech
they want to justify the sharing of
elon's real-time location data okay
that's scary and it says to me they want
him dead
I know it's a meme where like these
leftists will be like they want you dead
that's it that's the Republican party
but like if they're actively calling for
violence if they've gone and thrown
molotovs into police vehicles and smash
windows and quite literally killed
dozens of people in the May uh George
Floyd riots and then Elon Musk is like
you know for safety reasons I won't be
doing public events and we're gonna shut
down real-time location sharing and then
they go oh no oh oh geez our Free Speech
oh oh what are you doing yeah no they
just want him hurt
boxing people on the internet's Free
Speech anyway right it is it is I mean
it's free speech under the US
Constitution in in the colloquial sense
of telephones and like you could put a
piece of paper on a telephone pole that
showed a guy's face with his address
that was legal but now that we have the
Internet it's another realm of of
function and this kind of thing is not
it's not like benefiting Society to dox
people so I don't see why we've
supported as a form of free speech I
mean I guess it's a challenge it is free
speech you're allowed to say so and so
lives here it's it we had a phone book
you know before you growing up there's
the White Pages you can Google search
someone's address it's very very easy
so it's tough to justify when on social
media they say don't post someone's
address when you can just Google it and
see it if you want to however I still do
agree there's there's no idea expressed
in Sharing someone's physical location
there's probably some exemptions to this
like if someone was at like the Bohemian
Grove or something in real time and
you're like they're here now look
so I have to wonder if there's an a
potential negative downside to this if
if let's say for instance Bill Gates is
in real time at Epstein Island and
someone shares that can they get banned
or is Elon going to be alive no no it's
okay you're exposing him being absina I
know I think he's going to be like
real-time location sharing is wrong
erase that
what do you think look
I just keep coming back to the
fundamental point that your personal
physical safety and the safety
especially of your kids of your family
is one of the most important things that
we've lost sight of um amongst all of
this and so anything that's going to
again this is a this this is a private
platform
um that to make it so that at least it
makes it a little bit harder for someone
to actually find out where you are when
there's real threats against someone
who's high profile like that makes a ton
of sense you know again it's you just go
back and you juxtapose it against the
stuff that they actually were trying to
take down the things that they were
trying to flag is misinformation
disinformation false information in in
their eyes was totally fine and
acceptable but something that's actually
going to physically threaten somebody or
their family to say that that's somehow
wrong is is is just lacks common sense
it's setting everything else aside yeah
I think we also have to be careful to
also respect
um journalism here because I I could see
this being used to hurt journalism
especially when it comes to individuals
like Bill Clinton meeting the people
that were investigating him on the
tarmac uh with the with the head of the
DNC like someone going to the Bilderberg
meeting some prominent individuals going
and colluding with corporate individuals
or like the prime minister of New
Zealand going to Blackrock I think those
are all newsworthy events how do we
cover them without also compromising
people's safety how do we cover them
without being censored online I think
those are bigger questions that I I'm
kind of left here after all this I think
you just don't want to dox them in real
time like if someone goes if I'm
reporting if I'm doing a live stream
outside of the Bilderberg meeting right
and then Klaus Schwab or let's just say
Eric Schmidt you know walks down the
street which has happened to me I go up
to him I'm like hey Eric Schmidt what
are you doing here is that considered
something that will get me punished or
banned I I hope not you know it raises
some questions here
that I think should be answered yeah
because it's legal to publicly to record
someone in public yeah because it is in
the public interest
is your politician meeting with the
corporate heads uh your politician
meeting with secret groups of shadowy
Elites behind closed doors making
decisions for the general public is
something that is important but there
are also a lot of crazy people out there
that do want to hurt people and that's
out of your control how do you mitigate
the dangers with with actual reporting I
don't know I don't have that answer
um but you know I think the law says one
thing right now right like what what's
what's the legal basis for for all of
this
well I mean look on Twitter again it's
it's a private platform and so Elon Musk
can make whatever rules he wants for his
private platform but I think it's I
think there's a difference there's a
difference between CNN or fox or
whomever interviewing some Senator
standing in front of the Capitol
building that's something that's not
going to attract a crazy that's
something that's not going to make it
that much easier for some Rando to
follow that person to plot things out
it's a totally different deal if you've
got like a flight tracker that's got
your real-time location I mean would we
be okay with a GPS device that someone
put on your car
right and then they mapped it and then
anyone in the world could know exactly
where your car was at any point in time
and someone created a Twitter bot that
was reporting on your location I I mean
I don't think so no I don't think that
would be good I'm just I'm finding it
all funny because the left screams about
stochastic terrorism
where it's the the old concept oh won't
someone rid me of this priest they're
like you know uh China right chick lives
of tick tock as a stochastic terrorist
who you know incites indirectly all of
this hatred so that people know to go do
these things it's like okay shut up like
you're literally calling for violence
and then demanding we get to know
exactly where Elon Musk is right come on
right as they also say that words are
violent as they're telling everyone that
having a scientific debate on a
procedure that's been rushed through
without any long-term studies even just
questioning that is dangerous and it's
going to lead to murder I mean these are
very nonsensical very emotionally driven
individuals that clearly are there
serving an agenda rather than trying to
have an honest conversations about what
is right about our rights and and about
what we should have is sacred and that
is our ability to to say what we want as
long as we're not hurting anyone who
decides how people get hurt again that's
up in the air here and I'm left with
that question I don't have an answer to
it myself maybe if you're if you're
doxing someone that's in a secure
location like you said someone went into
a building then maybe that's less
dangerous than if you're doxing someone
that's out on the street out in the open
maybe that there's something there what
is what does Elon think it's going to
happen once we're all neuralinked and
and assume assume it's decentralized
assume it's centralized there's there's
no way if you increase the speed of
information tenfold 100 fold hooking
people's brains right to the machine
everyone will know where everyone is all
the time and there's no there's no
blocking that information you can't do
it right and then I would think there
would be huge amounts of rapidly
escalating violence that would then
settle and then you would have a sense
of calm but then you would know who was
going to be violent before they were
violent so you could stop them and then
you're in pre-crime which is like
minority minority report where they're
arresting people that haven't even done
anything yet so I don't like that maybe
I mean depending on where we go with
neuralink what might happen is the AI
will start track it'll track everyone's
brain patterns and then it will be like
there's a 97.3 percent of the time when
there's a mass shooting the brain
patterns look like this in this part of
the brain within an hour of the attack
and then all of a sudden some dudes
walking down the street and you know the
the pre-crime unit comes and grabs them
and cuffs them and says you're about to
commit a crime we could tell by tracking
your brain they'll do that and then
they'll go to the guy's trunk and
they'll find all these guns and we see
it's proof that we can do it and then I
could see them starting like an entire
you know a sector of the government as
pre-crime and then all of a sudden it's
work it's not working sometimes they're
getting people but it's all for your
safety it's all for your health it's all
for the greater good Ian for the for the
for the common man yes for the
collective live in the Pod eat the bugs
and plug into the New Orleans I think
we're better off and it will benefit
society and space and reality better as
a borg unit or as a a bunch of defined
benefit like you know increase
Prosperity growth you know diminish
um you know entropy if you followed Star
Trek stuff you know there was a board
Queen who was a centralized unit yeah
and the the Borg Queen was like an
independent mind that controlled the
whole network of its benefit maybe a
decentralized borg I've never seen a
fantasy decentralized Borg unit that
might work better I think it's bad
either way benefit is is it's an opinion
I guess but some people probably think
that all humans Network together is a
good thing and they want to Borg that
just seems like you're dead it seems
like every individual human dies at that
moment and then what you end up with is
this Collective Hive of noise of of no
merit it's just a buzz it's just a
machine
I think individuality is is beautiful I
think each little unique unique
snowflake you know is something of value
so that's what's worrying to me about
this idea of of norlink in the long run
but I don't know whatever we'll see
where we go how about that that's weird
yeah that's a ghost with the ghost in
the show basically a lot of this stuff
is what I reminisce immediately but but
at least in Ghost in the Shell for those
that are familiar anime and manga like
you're an individual yeah they cyberize
your brain with Nanobots and then you
can interface with computers and stuff
correct but the reality of what would
happen as we're already seeing with
Twitter is that we'd become a hive like
we're already turning into that just
because we have cell phones as it is
which is creepy or do you think you'll
get the neural net at any point Gene
you know look I I who knows probably not
I'm I'm much more of an individualist
um myself I don't like the idea of any
kind of machine planted in me but that's
me
um so you know look but I think the
point Timmy just made which is you see
the way right now
the the spheres of influence in the
power centers who have been using social
media and who have been using these
Avenues of communication in the media
have already formed a lot of this group
think in our society and we see the
dangers that are associated with that
when we have things like certain certain
people are determining what's true and
what's false and anything else is
censored in the shutdown and you're not
allowed you're not allowed to say
anything and we're already you know you
already see some of that today in a way
that you didn't see 10 20 30 years ago
at all and that's just based on our you
know modern modern communication and in
technology and social media thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time